my parents gonna flip
[Laughter]
I'm a little nervous right now oh boy
you guys are crazy this is gonna be fun
this is a very important question does
size matter I've never been intimate
with a guy and got to the point where I
was like oh my gosh you're too big or oh
my gosh you're too small I mean it's you
are who you are and I think you got to
end up like you know figuring out just
have fun for me size doesn't matter
that won't be everyone I don't know I
think it's more about the intimacy that
you shared with someone how do you
figure out who's topping or bottoming
and do you ask beforehand I do ask
beforehand but I do it in a very unusual
way I ask people if they prefer to be
bigger little spoon I don't ask
beforehand oftentimes I'm like super
surprised at what happens in the bedroom
and what people like does it hurt to
bottom it can hurt if the person is too
big if there's not enough Lube use
people also say it's the responsibility
of the top to prepare the bottom so that
it doesn't hurt us much get them more
relaxed they may hurt for the first two
or three minutes but after that it's
pretty okay how do you prepare yourself
if you're bottoming you have to take
your body signals into consideration
like if you just had a lot of greasy
foods I stick with things that are going
to kind of help you relieve yourself
fruits vegetables soups you can feel if
your stomach is like backed up you'll
kind of know whether or not it's going
to be a good situation or not there are
gonna be times when you have sex with
somebody and you get your day and it is
okay it's a natural process you might
freak you out do not make them feel bad
is there a technique to topping for anal
sex don't just like plunge yourself into
someone like that is that's a no-no
that's gonna be huge turnoff and taking
your time making sure that they're aware
of where you are you're aware of where
you are a guy who has a prostate which
the prostate is like your little fun
area in your butt and if you hit that
prostate correctly then the bottom can
have the most amazing orgasm ever
because I will say that the best sex is
when the other person is being pleased
to their liking cuz when you know that
they're being pleased you can be pleased
as well do you ever compromise and top
or bottom when you don't know
it's not a really big problem because I
like to do both initially when I first
came out I was really dead set on being
a top and I think one of my biggest
hang-ups was just kind of gender roles
and masculinity does being versatile or
being a bottom does that in encroach in
my masculinity ultimately no how often
you get tested and you're sexually
active I get tested every couple months
because some sti's don't show up on
tests right away there can be weeks or
sometimes even months in between the
time a person gets infected and when
they will show up positive on a test
there's lots of STI is that sometimes
you don't even have any symptoms I get
tested every three months I am on prep
or a mantra vada so it is an HIV
preventative drug and one of the big
things about that is that even when
you're on it you are required to get
your blood tested and everything every
three months that is a really really
great way of me knowing my status
knowing how I am how do you know if the
other guy has been tested and how would
you go about asking you if you don't
know if a person has been tested and
they've not told you then ask and be
willing then to to also share your
experiences with being tested I will say
no matter what even if you ask somebody
you're not positive about their answer I
mean just be cautious and think any time
you go into a sexual situation somebody
could have anything unless you see the
paperwork and unless you see the proof
you're really not gonna know what's the
most important thing about sex to be
really connected with someone else and
to have that energy and that passion I
think that's the most important thing
with sex something that's important
about sex is consent and communication
by consent I mean whether or not you
truly want to go through the act of
having sex and what kind of sex you want
to have with someone
they want to have sex with you and what
sort of sex they they want to have read
people's body language a lot people
aren't always verbal about things they
may be a little cautious they may be a
little wary but just take in mind other
people's actions you're gay sex is
you're gay sex and it's beautiful
there's a space for you regardless of
what you like or what you don't like
just have fun enjoy
[Music]